as a woman of color there's been a big
conversation going on I want to get your
take on it
Kendall got all this backlash for the
afro and people saying that was it was
cultural appropriation do you feel like
that was warranted or that it was blown
out of proportion it's so funny we were
just talking about that too she did that
shoot so long ago and she like showed me
the photo she was like what I was like
oh my god people are gonna like come at
you like I told her the moment yeah and
then she was talking to me about it as
well too and it's kind of like there are
white women that have curly hair exactly
yeah back then it's also like Vogue and
editorial so it's like they experiment a
lot with things but I do understand like
in this point in time like it's very
sensitive you have to go we're careful
yeah yeah you got to be a little careful
and just expect that people are going to
but at some times people do just reach
for things because they just like want
something to talk about like sometimes
people like spin headlines to like make
it seem like it's bigger than what it is
yeah things like I think that it's like
there are white women that have curly
hair so you can't like completely like
say that it was that inappropriate you
understand the sensitivity of it right
you understand that it could be slightly
offensive to someone but then they also
have to realize that it's not fully
culture appropriation yeah so do you not
even in this editorial with it it's
common for one to have curly hair as
well it wasn't like a tiger if it was
like this so now just like girl what are
you doing okay like you already know
that that's not how it goes like you
know that does not fly or anybody but do
you think in those instances where that
you're a model or you're an artist and a
lot of times you have a team around you
that's putting together this vision do
you feel in the moment that you should
speak up or is that something that it's
creative and we should be a little bit
more light-hearted about it I think that
you should you should speak up sometimes
it's it's hard yeah in this industry
sometimes and you're in the moment
sometimes you don't even think about it
like you're not thinking about if it'll
affect there are those people that do
think immediately and then there's those
people that aren't thinking like we're
all human we're not like perfect all the
time and we're not doing it on purpose
yes it's not what the intent like let me
do this I'm gonna make
I'm gonna make everybody bad but that's
what people think like on me from the
outside looking in that's what some
people think I know that I've said
things that people just say not fond of
and it's just like you grow and you
learn you make mistakes it's just that
we're making mistakes and like the
public eye exactly so it's we have to be
a lot more careful about the things that
we do but just understanding that people
are human and and everything and
everything they're gonna do is right and
that's that's also part of the reason
why like people in the spotlight don't
like to share too much because it
consistently getting critiqued on things
like nitpicking and just like everything
that they do is like wrong like nothing
they can use right and or offensive
exactly
[Music]